pizza eine sache die beliebt ist wie
kaum etwas anderes auf der welt pizza
ist die beliebteste speise der deutschen
und nicht nur das sondern die
beliebteste speise der welt glücklich
ich habe nachgeschaut und es gibt eine
pizza dies die königin und die mutter
aller pizzen pizza napoletana politische
pizza reinster handwerkskunst geschützt
als unesco welterbe und in der
zubereitung dieser speise der beste der
besten der weltmeister zu sein erfordert
und caspar thier können der mann der
dieses können aufbringt packt seine
pizza in deutschland und sein name ist
francesco ja solar
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und ich habe mich auf den weg zu ihm
gemacht um die beste pizza der welt zu
essen
angekommen und man glaubt nicht wirklich
dass es hier die beste pizza der welt
gibt ist sie zwar so ein bisschen
italienisch aus weil das hier mitten in
der altstadt ist wer sehr dörflich und
man würde es wirklich nicht erwarten
aber hier sind wir und gerade bei diesem
wetter freue ich mich jetzt auch so eine
richtig schöne und leckere warme ich
glaube so wie es noch ganz was auf ihn
zukommt nicht nur so eine schöne die
beste der welt die beste der welt ja
dass durch ihre
es wird anders irgendwie das ist so
normal alles irgendwie ich habe
irgendwie so sexy so richtig normal
sondern ein echter italiener ist jetzt
fast gedacht
wofür ist impressions erst ein es könnte
der italiener sein daneben an das
einzige was was verrät sind wände die
einfach übergangen sind mit auszeichnet
hier ist 2009 bestes bester pizzabäcker
in europa
2021 besten verhält es ist wirklich ihre
also aber ansonsten es sieht einfach aus
wie der lagen denn jeder so weiß ich um
die ecke der klassische italiener in der
stadt aber auch geil ist also dass das
haus den charme versprüht hier die beste
pizza aber es ist einfach vor möglicher
ort wo jeder hinkommen kann man die chic
sein muss man einfach nur genießen kann
was man schon mal sagen muss ist nicht
unglaublich
zugute
[Musik]
hätten die so parfüm ausgespülte hoffen
dass kraft aber ansonsten wirklich in
die karten
sagen wir auf die karte und ich bin
wirklich gespannt was kosten
also für mich ist eine echte ehre ich
bin schon unfassbar gestanden ich freue
mich auch wenn wir gleich mal ein
bisschen quatschen
die
geschichte zeige wie
[Musik]
wichtig unser bisheriger kostet 7 euro
50 ersten statement dann können wir 214
heute esse ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
was wir jetzt haben werden wir hätten
gerne einmal die hits aus favorit und
einmal dritter
also wird der geruch ist unfassbar gut
unfassbar also das so wenn man so
richtig und dann wird über einen kalten
straßen nicht mehr so in kürze das plus
wenn es einmal den klassiker eine pizza
margherita besteht so das muss sein das
ist das benchmarking und pizza britin
steht mit büffelmozzarella feature
kirschtomaten steinpilzen und
geräucherter vor roland und haben wir
sagen es tut mir auch leid dass ich
solche sachen überhaupt zeigen muss so
dass ihr euch das zeigen dass ihre frau
sehen uns nicht essen können müssen ab
jetzt immer so das thema holt euch was
er will ich bei diesem video heute
danke sehr das ist sie also
das ist mal ganz kurz analysieren wir
haben nicht diesen getigerten rand den
man häufig sieht wir haben nicht dieses
so marmoriert haben ja mehr so ein
kleines bild aber vor allem haben wir
einen hohen rang wir haben die flachen
boden und ich bin gespannt wie kürze
auch von union aussehen wird
das ist perfekt von christa auf den rand
draufgepackt
da ist auch nicht viel substanz führen
das ist nur luft erkunden ist
genauso bild wird ich weiß gar nicht was
ich noch sagen sollte alle pizzen dass
es vielleicht charakteristisch ich weiß
es nicht haben in der mitte noch mal so
ein kleines mozzarella pech also für
mich gar nicht bereit das ist ja eine
große streitfrage beim pizzabacken macht
man basilikum vorher oder nachher auch
dabei dass beide vorher und nachher
ich habe einfach mal essen ich fühle
mich noch nicht einfach essen aber durch
ist sie mit händen
natürlich schneiden sie auch mit am
besten wird er mich hier so
bloßzustellen hat schon jemals pizza mit
gabel und messer gehört die schneidet
sich auch wie butter und ich frage nicht
wirklich bestimmt werden wir nicht alle
geheimnisse erfahren denn wir gleich
noch mit von jazz besprechen aber ich
frage mich was macht sie zur besten der
welt und jetzt kommt ist weiter stützen
sie verneigt sich natürlich verteidigt
ein bisschen der besten kritik
[Musik]
so gerührt war
in den augen der alte preis noch
minutenlang ich schwöre dir auch alles
von dieser ansprache die zutaten es ist
einfach es ist einfach perfekt und
möchte nicht besser weil man
merkt es ist nicht nur die beste pizza
das sind die besten zutaten der welt und
kann hier der rand
also logisch wer hier den rand liegen es
gehört bestraft der ist knusprig der
isst salziges
war für nur an er bekommt wie sich alles
verbindet wieso die sieben dieser sanfte
käse
was versteht man nicht mehr so sitzt er
schon seit fünf minuten da seitdem der
probiert habe
was soll ich sagen das ist alles schon
gesagt es ist die beste der welt dass
wir das erleben dürfen seht ihr diese
wabenstruktur im branden jetzt guck mal
bitte
erlebt dieser rand lebt einfach das ist
nicht mehr normal dieser mann ist
genauso gut wie das innere und das
innere ist unglaublich gut ich sage
ehrlich noch nie geglückt preis gestellt
müssen sich auch als er müsste
eigentlich sperren denn wenn ein brief
wäre dann wäre jetzt
das war jetzt gerade also die
weltmeister plätze die wir gegessen und
das hier ist eine eigenkreation des
weltmeisters die pizza sascha riether
die geschmackvolle und fast mal viele
kräftige schmecken in sachen japan sah
und denke werden in der sterneküche mit
parmesan chip auch hier wieder das
muster der geruch sein
erster bis nimmt mich auf die hütte in
den bergen von meinem auto spart man
dabei schon ein paar tage haben die
frische pilze gesammelt fulvia die
mutter nächsten wahnsinnige brechen
hatten besorgte gekommen
pilze das ist essen ist ein emotional
macht das essen das ein philosophisch
denkt so ist das und wie kann ich wie
kann ich das wertschätzen das ist für
mich die beste pizza dich niemals
vergessen habe ich will ich will es
nicht trennen aber das ist die unterste
und das habe ich mir das abbrechen wir
müssen jetzt einbrechen gruppe müssen
jetzt abbrechen und ich freue mich jetzt
wirklich dem genie hinter dieser pizza
vielleicht noch ein paar fragen gestellt
und wir wollen ihn kennenzulernen das
ist wirklich da ist so ein kranker tag
wird ich sehe mir also leute francisco
ayala lasso er ist nicht nur vier
sondern auch hier also ich muss mich
gerade schon gedanken ich möchte ich
wollte ihm die hand geben einfach für
diese kurzarbeit ist ich habe doch mal
gegessen sind also dieser es war einfach
unglaublich gibt also eine frage wollte
ich dir stehen das freut mich das wollen
wir ja möglich eine frage möchte ich die
ganz schön bist man pizza mit den händen
oder mit besteck sowie happel essen die
alt-lotter folio das portemonnaie die da
meinen einmal gefallen ist
gibt es hier drei formel also ppp das
eis barnaby polo also hähnchen brot und
pizza muss man mit essen also genau
sagen dass nämlich machen muss um es mit
dem stecken könnte
ist das jetzt seit dem diese
auszeichnung als bester pizzabäcker der
welt da hat sich was verändert sowie
stolz ist man ja also am anfang habe ich
das ganze nicht realisieren das kommt
danach mit radio fernsehen und zeitung
gemeldet haben klar jetzt ist dadurch
mehr kundschaft kommt weil die kommen
auch von weiten ja ja wir kommen auch
aus köln wir haben jetzt und stuttgart
wenn jemand sagt dann besser werden also
die leute diese neuigkeit wollen sie
jetzt nicht probieren wie schmeckt ja
von einem weltmeister also ich wirklich
so kann also ich habe mich auch gefragt
warum jemand was bedeutet dass du du
bist der italiener was bedeutet das für
den italiener das ist man ist auch
vorstellbar ja ich bin stolz dass ich
als italiener das erste mal dass es
passiert ist das super champ also wir
haben alle kategorie geworden in neapel
ja und was eigentlich jeder der in
deutschland lebten sie in deutschland
hat ja du hast gerade schon erzählt was
ist das geheimnis sein eigener trainer
haben ja sieben verschiedene mehlsorten
also und lerne jahren erfahrung habe ich
meine eigene zeit regiert aber was
wichtig war dass ich die gleiche pfizer
von pinkl ein in italien button wollte
da muss man für temperatur feuchtigkeit
messen die temperatur steigt temperatur
also was strike maschine temperatur
ph-wert von wasser zwar alles schön hund
gekommen dass gott sei dank hat es
geklappt hat uns gerade schon ganz pur
teuer erzählt er im supermarkt das
wasser gekauft milderung anderen ph wert
hat der leitung in der ampel also ganz
verrückt auf was man achten muss aber
wenn man der beste der welt da ist es ja
das ist dieses mal haben wir uns
vorbereitet war fünf tage vor der
abreise gemessen die gesagt dass jetzt
schon zweimal getroffen war es immer in
italien blamiert ph wert von 11 und das
war schon für meinen teil nicht mehr
richtig ich habe auch einen
italienischen austauschschüler ich habe
und ich habe ihm bestätigt wird die sec
habe in deutschland die bessere welt was
sagst du dazu und der hat eine harte
zeit in der die glauben das sind also
die jury habe man alle begeistert dass
wir das nicht praktisch in zehn
kategorien und internet präsentiert habe
und die haben ja selbst gesagt wie kann
ein hauch von deutschland das sind
bekommt das besonders das finde ich
eigentlich das habe ich auch gesagt es
gibt ja menschen die essen gar nicht den
rand was ist ja schon mal vom verstehen
aber bei dir ist der rand genauso lecker
an das innere der pizza dichtesten dran
und er schmeckt einfach so so geschockt
als wirklich lust ist sehr sehr zu
schätzen danke schön ich sage euch
wahnsinnig dass die wichtigste frage zum
schluss was ein spitzer die einfachste
marita gräve mozzarella am donnerstag
zahlen bis die ponys an käse und
pensionierungen oder ich hab ich schon
mal da merkt man nämlich die qualität
der zum keller haben danach werden kann
es war wirklich ein erlebnis eine frage
noch ein dann vielleicht noch für die
kamera eine pizza für uns machen
[Musik]
danke sehr
also ihr seht schon ich gehe nicht ich
war nicht zweieinhalb stunden zur besten
pizzeria der welt und g ohne pizza nach
hause aber was soll ich sagen ich muss
dann wirklich jetzt noch weiter darüber
nachdenken ich muss mir jetzt auch schon
sagen abseits der pizza die sind so
herzlich diesem so bescheiden kommen das
ist der weltmeister und er hat uns mit
offen er ist wieder der beste
pizzabäckerin er ist einfach der beste
der welt also wirklich die waren so nett
herzliche ganze familie wir sehen jetzt
gleich wieder was soll ich dazu noch
sagen leute ich glaub ich muss das ganze
eine bewertung fassen was soll ich sagen
es ist die beste pizza der welt
was hätte ich anders dazu sagen können
leute es war auf jeden fall ein erlebnis
dankeschön an francesco an seine familie
an das ganze team es war wunderbar ich
war wirklich einfach cool und wir sehen
uns von diesem video wieder schauer
francesco vorbei den könnt sein
instagram ist verdient gemacht